oh come on Wade I know you like rough
[Music]
Deadpool too I have just gotten back
from the theater and given that I'm
getting this one out quicker than I have
the less you reviews I will do that
thing that I haven't done in a while
which is stay spoiler free for as long
as I'm able to before getting into
specifics with the spoilers so if you
like Deadpool 1 you are probably gonna
enjoy this unless you wanted it to be
more than Deadpool 1 kind of again so
I'm I'm still kind of processing but
right now I'm fighting the instinct to
be a little bit disappointed now I also
don't want to overstate that because
it's not bad it's good and actually
there are parts there are segments
there's three in particular that I think
are flat-out great but there are there
are the overall what I had hoped for out
of this movie coming in was now that we
had had the first movie which was a fair
honestly at the end of the day despite
its odd structure and a fourth wall
breaking character was at the end of the
day a fairly straightforward origin
story for a superhero I was hoping
that's that they only needed that to
basically get it through the system and
then now that they have and they knew
audience is one and more they were gonna
go nuts with it they were really gonna
lean into some of the more out there and
outrageous and just bonkers kind of
stuff that Deadpool gets involved in and
they kind of don't like I said there are
bits there are moments but by and large
they use the same formula again of
having honestly strip out the jokes and
it's a very straightforward kind of
bog-standard superhero style story
there's not there's not that a lot that
feels unique about the core
concept of the film it's only the
trappings which make a Deadpool it's
it's the it's the costumes it's the
Asian equip from him it's that every now
and then fourth wall break but I wanted
them to I wanted them to mess with the
DNA of this thing a bit more I'm not
like have it not feel like Deadpool but
like really up the the percentage that
that was the feel of the character
himself as opposed to just him kind of
tweaking the nose of all the serious
folks I wanted that feel to bleed over
into the story but that isn't really
what happened
now that might to a certain extent just
be one of those issues that happens I
think especially with geeks which is
that we go in with a hope for the movie
we want to see and then we don't get it
and sometimes that means that there's a
movie that's good that we still don't
fully appreciate it's basically kind of
a weird twisty geek version of being
overhyped or overexcited about something
I'm not sure this is that though because
I didn't have very specific expected at
least in my experience when people tend
to have that happen to them it's usually
because like they're they had in their
idea like oh if I was gonna make this
movie this is what I would do and
they've got something specific in mind I
didn't I just had a general vibe a
general like percentage of serious to
just nuts
that I wanted that less serious more
nuts and I didn't have anything specific
that I wanted and I also do feel that
there is a difference between that thing
that happens when you just didn't get
the movie you wanted but and kind of
wasted potential which wasted is an
overstatement but I think there's missed
potential in this film and I think the
some of the sequences which are in my
mind the best sequences in the film
those show me glimpses of what this
could have been if they do
really cut loose and they kind of didn't
it's it's sort of the it's sort of the
funny paradox of these kinds of
franchises not that Deadpool is
necessarily like anything else but I
mean like something that is bold and
daring and is like a whole new thing it
like it comes out and you know whether
it's a TV show or a movie or a piece of
music an album whatever it comes out and
go whoa I was not expecting that I can't
do I can't now that they have clouds now
that they have like a safety net of
support I can't wait to see them really
go out on a limb but behind the scenes
they're going okay we took a big risk
and it paid off let's play it safe now
so that we don't lose the value of this
IP we've now created and so you end up
with something that doesn't I'm not
gonna say does nothing new but doesn't
feel as it doesn't feel nearly as bold
as the the first film did and I mean I
was I almost said to a certain extent it
can't but it could but it can't if it's
going to do more or less the same thing
again then it can't be as impactful as
fresh as just new because something
can't be new twice so since it can't be
new twice I think what you need to do
especially with a property like this is
go bigger go go crazier with it or in
the case of you know the more
straight-laced superhero films you dive
into character a bit more rather than
trying to go bigger you go more personal
you know which is kind of how things
like like Captain America the Winter
Soldier did that's not necessarily a
bigger scale story than the First
Avenger was but it's a more personal
story and then you know you had the mix
of personal and large-scale in civil war
but when you basically just sort of come
in and do more or less the same thing
again and the big part of the appeal the
first one was how fresh it was guess
what
it ain't fresh the second time around
and I
but mostly talking about how about sort
of my down issues with it and this I and
I'm now kind of annoyed with myself
because that makes us out actually more
negative than I want to be because I did
enjoy it and it was fun
and there are some things that are like
I said phenomenal the opening credits
sequence loved that there there's a
there's an action sequence in the middle
I don't even want to identify it because
I don't want you to start like spinning
your wheels trying to figure out what it
is that goes on but is the kind of
craziness that I wanted not to be
isolated moments but more baked into the
thing but there is a there's a sequence
in the middle that is awesome for that
and there's and there's a whole you know
a bunch of little great jokes moments
bits scattered across the thing so that
there is a lot here to to like it just
it seems content with just refreshing
what Deadpool was last time and for me
that that is a little bit disappointing
the the highlight for me I'm gonna have
to get into spoilers in a minute the
highlight for me has to be zazzy beats
as domino both in her performance and
the way the character is used in the
movie she at least to my taste she walks
away with this movie very much like
negasonic teenage warhead walked away
with the first movie even though
negasonic teenage were here it appears
in this one to this one this one is its
Domino I'm like oh god yeah give me more
of that and Ryan Reynolds is he knows
that pool he knows how to play Deadpool
and he's he's doing him pretty well
Brolin as cable works he's you know if
he's not selling it as hard as say he
sold fan OHS but the character he's
working
is a bit more broad and anyway he works
and and his and he's got the right
dynamic going on with Reynolds in terms
of being the real serious guy who just
he appreciates that this other guy has
uses but he really wishes he would just
shut up so that that that works well
there's some there's you know other
returning characters there's new
characters I'm not sure I can talk too
much about about the rest of this so
yeah that's the gist of it I it was good
I'm personally disappointed because I I
wanted them to I wanted them to really
try to outdo themselves and I feel like
for the film as a whole I didn't really
try to do that for a couple of sequences
they did but not for the film as a whole
so now getting into spoilers a little
bit
I feel like sort of some of my
irritation is actually well exemplified
by the opening stretch of the film
because Vanessa dies and that irritated
me because it's just something that I
hate like so we had a completed journey
an arc for a character and a couple in
the last movie and we want to do a
sequel but we wanted to feel as much
like the first one is possible we can't
have them have a happy home life oh okay
don't worry we'll just kill the love
interest and undo basically the entire
point of the climax of the last movie I
hate that I always hate that same reason
I hate alien 3 you know it's it I just I
hate that now the film did win me back a
little bit I mentioned the opening
credits sequence first of all it's the
song ashes by Celine Dion which if you
have not checked out that music video
check out that music video cuz it's
awesome and so it's that and it's this
very James Bond kind of a title sequence
and it's a lot of fun and they mess with
the credits like they did in the first
one
the credits are pretty much all in
reaction to Vanessa having gotten their
credits like are you kidding me
did they seriously just kill her what
the hell which was basically all my
thoughts and while I appreciate that
that was there and that did help a
little at the end of the day that really
kind of exemplifies my issues with the
movie because when you do something that
is standard or expected or not
particularly original but also go hey we
know that we did something unoriginal
like I can go okay well you recognize
that but then at the end of the day
structurally you still did it you just
did it while while going whoo
but you still did the same thing at the
end of the day so that yeah that kind of
annoys me and like I'd like I said the
acknowledgement of that does help it not
ruin the movie for me but I would rather
they just didn't do that at all I just
did something way you know less crappy
because I'm sorry killing off the love
interest from the previous movie in the
opening minutes of the sequel it's a
crappy thing to do especially when
they've got really great chemistry which
they do I know that you they have her
still appear because we've got the weird
afterlife thing going on and that's the
other thing with Deadwood the best
sequences are the ones that are really
just letting it rip with with being
irreverent and that tone is clashing
with this break the hero down bring them
to their lowest point thing that the
movie is doing narrative Lee so the
trappings you know keep trying to be oh
this is wacky fun times but the
structure of the story is really just he
just lost
everything he wants to die the other guy
the other major plot driver who is cable
also lost his family that you know this
is and frankly it's just played a bit
too straight its and it's too heavy cuz
I mean they played the the romance angle
and also you know some of the beats in
the original Deadpool were played
straight as well but there were also
moments that were not inherently as
heavy as this is being you know because
rescuing the girlfriend you know that's
that's a fairly like trope because at
the end of that he gets back everything
he was missing so we can still have fun
there this one he's trying for a bit of
symbolic redemption but he still lost
everything he loved that's a little too
heavy for a movie where a guy keeps
talking about his dick you know the the
the clash of tones they're not blending
as well as they were in the first film
but you know I keep I really don't mean
to be to be harping on the stuff that
bothered me is just as what's at the
forefront of my mind okay
some spoiler stuff that that was really
good the entire sequence x-force jumping
out of the helicopter they're all dead
all of them except Domino in like I said
domino domino rules love Domino in this
but that whole thing when you know when
they got down and bedlam hit the bus I
was like you see good no no I don't know
if he's dead but then shatter star okay
because I mean I don't I don't know what
the current standing of any of these
characters are but the only ones I knew
were we're shattered star and Domino and
so in my mind because I knew who they
were they were bigger characters with a
fan base so what when shattered star
oh god they're all gonna die then I was
just loving it I'm just going oh oh this
is fun and it was the kind of
irreverence that I really wanted out of
more of the movie because we just gone
through this extended assemble the team
thing and while that didn't work crap
which you know that was great I love
that I'd also love as part of the the
tail end when when he's got the time
thingy
the only one he saves is Peter bedlam or
zeitgeist or shatter star her the only
one we see him save his Peter that's
good that's a good call back I like that
too I don't know how many other people
even realize that I feel like it was the
only one who noticed but yes that was
great some of the action sequences were
pretty good that was another thing I was
hoping they were gonna up the action I
think they did pretty well especially
with with cable with the variety of
settings on the gun and the SH and his
sort of force field thing and the fact
that he could basically magnetized the
gun to his back all that played really
well so that was cool action stuff the
the kid who played Russell I don't know
him I think he was in for the wilderbe
but he you know what he did pretty well
you was called upon to be kind of
laughable but then also you know kind of
tragic and very angry and he pulled that
off pretty well the juggernaut I did
love the the music and the soundtrack
and you know the the big intone Montano
the choral voices but they're swearing
about how much crap the hero's away are
in because the juggernaut has shown up
that was a cool touch I enjoy that
although you know what again you want to
talk missed opportunity how didn't
nobody make and I'm the juggernaut [ __ ]
joke I mean that was I was like one of
the first major memes I remember
noticing after I
realized what a meme was and nobody
really alright
Oh Yukio negasonic teenage warhead 'he's
girlfriend she was great and weight
immediately just clicking with her that
was great
oh that was she was just this overly
peppy and and just yeah and I love the
whole thing where negasonic teenage
warhead is like yeah I got a girlfriend
what's your problem you babies like whoa
I got no broke with that but somebody
actually wants to date you you know that
that kind of stuff worked well but then
we had very repeated jokes I'm not
ultimately his payoff at the end worked
well enough I can't remember the taxi
drivers name but but he was he was kind
of a mix like there were times that
having him around was like okay and
there are other times than no but then
we've got like sort of the classic
mistake with comedy sequels which is
take one of the most memorable jokes do
it again but longer and bigger and they
do that with the baby hand joke now with
the baby legs and it's the exact same
joke it hasn't changed and it goes on
for an embarrassingly long amount of
time then and it's just it's the same
joke and you know instances like that
didn't help either so ultimately for me
this was a very mixed bag of a film
because I mean you saw the smile on my
face when it's good and when it's
clicking and when it's doing stuff that
is way more tweaking the nose of
super-heroes not just with a snarky line
but with like a fundamental plot thing
like having the whole team that he put
together died before they even get to
where they're trying to get to it's
great
that's the minority of the film though
and I don't know I just I had hoped for
or more so that's me I'm
this is turning into a year of
disappointing sequels for me not all of
them but a fair amount of stuff that I
was really looking forward to is just
mmm it's it's not quite getting there
we had Jessica Jones season two stranger
things season two now this you know
although stranger things was last year
wasn't it
I don't know I'm losing all sense of
time I'm doing almost a video a day
lately time oh boy space is warped and
time is bendable so we'll wrap up on
that note Deadpool 2 did you see it what
did you think about it
whatever you thought drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it you
can you can support me on patreon if you
think what I do is worth supporting you
can follow me on Twitter there's a
podcast there's t-shirts you can buy
links for all that stuff's down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]